a great deal of intelligence can be
invested in ignorance if the need for
illusion is high and so if you really
need to believe something no matter how
absurd it is if you have the
intelligence you can make yourself
believe it through your own arguments
and that's the danger of of intelligent
people is that they can convince
themselves of stupid arguments
gwendobogle welcome to the show thanks
chris nice to be here dude you're
crushing it at the moment that audience
capture
uh article that you wrote on sub stack
has gone absolutely everywhere when
someone posts something that's one of my
friend's work in a group chat but but i
don't post it there's this weird sense
of
like ownership or jealousy i'm like no
that's my friend that's no that's
supposed to be me that's posting that
but dude i'm so happy to see how
everything's blowing up for you at the
moment thanks man yeah it's appreciated
i think a lot of it's probably due to
you as well like spreading word about me
you know so thanks for that that's it
part of the bogel cult uh but so for
people that aren't familiar with these
episodes you do these huge mega threads
on twitter you talk about cognitive
biases human nature psychological
effects group think all this stuff uh i
fall in love with them and then we go
through them today i've got some i
actually brought some from home i've got
some that i've made already so i'll
bring some of mine into it as well we're
just going to go through them and we'll
break some down so the first one and
this is my favorite one from your most
recent mega thread which will be linked
in the show notes below
gwinder's theory of bespoke [ __ ]
many don't have an opinion until they're
asked for it at which point they cobble
together a viewpoint from whim and half
remembered hearsay before deciding that
this two-minute old makeshift opinion
will be their hill to die on
yeah so i think the last time i was on
uh this show we talked about
how social media has made uh opinions
more important than deeds and people are
judged by their opinions
and
i think one of the sort of side effects
of that is that now everybody feels the
need to have an opinion on everything
but obviously the problem with this is
that you know people can't really
um
do the research to actually back up all
the opinions that they have and so
what do they do uh they just make [ __ ]
up you know
and i've seen this on social media since
i joined twitter in 2014 i've seen this
happen with regular
occurrence with regular consistency and
it's kind of
i think it's something that really is
just it comes naturally to people to
feel the need
to opine on subjects because it makes
them feel connected and it makes them
feel like they're part of the
conversation and it also obviously
because of the opinion economy
it's something that people feel the need
to do in order to bolster their own
status and so people just end up just
talking and um
you know
it it's it's remarkable how often this
happens it happens with pretty much
everything i mean if you look at
for instance let's take a a subject like
fracking for instance
um most people have probably read like
one or two articles on fracking right
maybe from the bbc or from new york
times right
and suddenly everybody becomes an expert
on fracking you know it's just after
reading one article on fracking
everybody has a strong opinion on this
you know oh yeah it's great you know for
the uh energy efficient efficiency or
it's really bad for the environment and
none of these people really know what
they're talking about you know and i
think this is one of the dangerous
things about this is that
the need to have an opinion
sort of compels people to take a stance
on things that they don't know anything
about
and
what that does is it just pollutes
the sort of conversation it pollutes the
national conversation or the global
conversation
excuse me it pollutes the global
conversation with
garbage basically you know people just
ill thought out um opinions things that
people don't really um understand
they're just sort of talking
and i think it's one of them
what i find what i find interesting here
is the fact that it's their new hill to
die on so not only is the opinion brand
new but for some reason people feel
like existentially connected to it that
letting go of the opinion would be
tantamount to their own destruction
yeah i mean so one of the things with
this is that
once people
utter an opinion in public even if it's
a really really poorly thought out
opinion
they feel the need to defend that
opinion because
if they don't then they're going to look
inconsistent you know if they if they go
back on that opinion if they change
their mind they have this perception
that they're going to
be they're gonna sort of be perceived as
weak or stupid and so their egos compel
them to defend even the worst opinions
you know because the fact is they want
to remain consistent
uh and
do you think that part of this is to do
with the fact that typically our
opinions wouldn't have been set in stone
and referenceable
for almost all of human history whereas
our entire lives now are there to be
linked and screenshotted until the day
we die
yeah absolutely i mean i think what
people would have done in the past
because human ego is as old as humans so
people always want to be right they've
always wanted to be right throughout
history
but i think the way that people did this
before the internet was that they
quietly changed their opinions
and hoped that nobody would notice
you know um
but now people can't do that because
there's a public record of everything
you know
so people are compelled by the record by
the public ledger
to just defend the worst opinions that
they've ever had you know the blockchain
of opinion errors yeah yeah yeah yeah
and this is i think very dangerous thing
because it means that people are stifled
they're not allowed to grow they're not
allowed to develop they're not allowed
to change
people sort of remain static in their
in their lives because of this you know
they think oh my god you know if i
change my opinion you know everybody's
gonna know they're gonna see this this
post from like 2014 and i can see this
post from 2020
and that's that fear i think
is responsible for a lot of people being
very pig-headed and stubborn i think in
their
in their beliefs they double down on
their worst beliefs yeah this links in
with so many of the previous ones that
we've spoken about one of my favorites
from all of our conversations was an
absurd ideological belief is a show of
fealty and a threat display
so this kind of
explains why people might choose group
ideology or group think over rationality
and reason itself then the fact that our
opinions are significantly more visible
than our deeds adds another layer on top
of that because we are our opinions
rather than our actions now and then you
know you continue to roll this a little
bit further forward dude i love that um
right next one next one when intelligent
people affiliate themselves to ideology
their intellect ceases to guard against
wishful thinking and instead begins to
fortify it causing them to inadvertently
mastermind their own delusion and to
very cleverly become stupid
yeah so this is actually a very robust
finding in psychology this is one that's
been sort of replicated many many times
so it's a very reliable finding
and
there's so much evidence for it i mean
you know there was one experiment i've
forgotten the name of the uh the
researcher but what they did was um they
basically
they got people to um sort of post their
opinions and then what they did is they
they rearranged the opinions they sort
of reworded the opinions so that they
were disguised as other people's
opinions and then they asked these
people like what do you think of this
opinion
and they would suddenly be like oh you
know this is wrong
um
i don't believe this at all you know
this is whoever wrote this is stupid you
know even though it was their own
opinion
and so you know when people were asked
why why do you object with this they had
a whole list of like reasons they'd be
like oh well this part is wrong that
part's wrong so they were actually
critically analyzing their own opinions
and they were dissecting them they were
finding what's wrong with their own
opinions but they were doing this
unwittingly which showed that they
actually possessed mental faculties
um but that these mental faculties were
being misdirected in a way to sort of
essentially destroy their own opinions
and um this i mean this is something
that you see every day on twitter as
well you see
people using um
logic and you know things like
symmetrisms and um what's a syllogism so
syllogism is like a logical argument
where you say like if a um if a then b
if b then c
therefore um a
then c
so it's like just a way of making a
simple argument and um you know people
will use logic and things like they'll
use sometimes very sophisticated
arguments and they'll often
they'll mention cognitive biases this is
the irony of it they'll mention
cognitive biases but they'll always
apply these cognitive biases to other
people never to themselves you know and
i'm guilty of this as well i mean i'm
sure you know i've made many many errors
as a result of my own cognitive biases
but i'm much it's much easier for me to
see them in other people than it is for
me to see it myself and so
all of our knowledge of mental models
cognitive biases all of these things you
know we can be the most knowledgeable
people in the world we can have all of
this knowledge of all the biases that
other people
that well that human beings um you know
suffer from and we would only really see
these in other people because of that
blindness and that blindness is why
intelligent people when they affiliate
themselves to ideology
they become more dangerous than stupid
people who are affiliated to ideology
because the intelligent people can come
out with rationalizations and they can
come out with very clever arguments that
support stupid positions
you know and so i mean like thomas seoul
he had this great line which he said
that you know he spoke of this idea said
it was an idea so absurd only an
academic could believe it you know
and that really sums it up because you
can spend your whole life you know sort
of just coming out with the best
arguments but if you
are if your mind is blinded by ideology
or by tribalism then you will put your
great intellect
to uh the service of
stupid ends idiotic ends basically it's
a very a very fast powerful car being
driven in the wrong direction
yeah oddly a slower car would do less
destruction that's it it's like this
this other saying i think it was
um
sorbelo
who said that
uh a great deal of ignorance can be
invested
in no sorry a great deal of intelligence
can be invested in ignorance if the need
for illusion is high
and so if you
if you really need to believe something
no matter how absurd it is
if you have the intelligence you can
make yourself believe it through your
own arguments you know you can convince
yourself and that's the danger of of
intelligent people is that they can
convince themselves of stupid arguments
dude i love it all right next one this
is one of this is one of mine so i found
a guy
adam mastro
stroyoni uh butchering his surname but
he's got a sub stack as well that people
should go and check out so this is the
fading affect bias the goodness and
badness of memories fade over time but
the badness face fades faster some bad
memories even become good memories while
good memories rarely become bad memories
it makes sense that both joint pain fade
with time stuff just feels less intense
when it's farther away but why does pain
fade faster it's because when bad stuff
happens to us our psychological immune
systems turn on we start to rationalize
why would i want to be in a relationship
with someone who doesn't want to be with
me we downplay breakups happen all the
time in high school it's no big deal we
distance i never liked it that much
anyway and we distract i'm going to go
and play video games these emotional
processes function like emotional
antibodies taking the sting out of bad
memories we don't use them on good
memories so good memories keep their
lustre longer everything is temporary
bad stuff especially
tragedy plus time equals comedy is the
closest thing psychology has to a
chemical equation
beautiful yeah i mean yeah i couldn't
agree more i mean um yeah cause i've
heard about this this bias and i have a
theory about it actually
um which is
that
i think we we've covered negativity bias
didn't we we did it in the first
episode that we did
and um so just for your audience just a
refresher so negativity bias is the
tendency for people to focus on and
remember
bad news over good news and the reason
for this is because bad news constituted
an existential threat whereas good news
didn't so you had to pay more attention
in order to survive to bad news
so
one of the side effects of the
negativity bias is that it fills your
head up with a lot of bad memories a lot
of really really horrific and
sort of um
traumatic
events
and you need a kind of safety valve
against this you need some way of being
able to continue to live your life
without you know wanting to commit
suicide
from all these negative emotions as a
result of the negative bias and so i
think that this fading effect bias acts
as a kind of safety valve in that it
allows us to release all of that sort of
pent up negative energy as a result of
all of these negative memories that we
have so that we can
retain a sense of hope and retain a
sense of motivation and you know feeling
that we can actually do things in life
um so i think it's like a psychological
defense mechanism i think
which is pretty much what adam seems to
have said yeah yeah for sure i also
think that makes a lot of sense imagine
if you didn't have the fading affect
bias and you just accumulated this
ever-increasing intensity of negative
experiences throughout your life every
caveman would have been a nihilist right
yeah no one would have ever got anything
done because they would have been bowed
under the weight of their brother that
died 55 years ago or something
it's a nice
thing to remember here though that not
only can bad things
fade and become less bad but sometimes
can actually become a perverse source of
joy that yeah tragedy plus time equals
comedy
is true i look back on some of the
things that i thought were kind of close
to destruction back in the day and it's
now almost got a humorous quality to it
because you've come out the other side
and the same doesn't happen which really
should give us reason
to discount how bad bad things feel
is you're going through something not
only do you know that this isn't going
to last forever not only will you know
that the memories are going to fade over
time and won't feel as intense but maybe
even in
five years time genuinely be a source of
something that's i don't know valuable
or at least funny yeah
i think um like i did i posted a tweet
um about how regret is a sign of
progress
and i think that
that that basically applies to this
because if you if you have a bad event
in your life if you have a bad sort of
uh incident and you learn from it then
the
then the sort of there's no more need to
feel any pain because you've learned
from it you're a different person you've
grown since that that occurred you know
there's been so many times in my life
where i've just done something you know
just god awfully embarrassing and i've
just made me cringe you know and burn up
just thinking about it but then after
time you change your behaviors and you
realize that that wasn't that's no
longer you the person that did that is
no longer you you're a different person
now oh and it allows you to
grow and once you've grown you no longer
need to feel that negative sort of
feeling in a sense so you know it kind
of just gets ejected as a sort of
unnecessary waste product that's a very
interesting way to think about regrets
that the fact that you still regret
doing something
maybe a little bit of an indicator that
you haven't transcended it or fixed the
thing that it's based on anymore i had
um
[ __ ] who wrote the book daniel pink uh
the power of regret he brought that book
at the start of this year i spoke to him
while i was in new york uh and he used
the same thing he basically said that
regret is the opportunity to remind
yourself that you're genuinely invested
in something it gives you a direction
that you're supposed to look at when you
move forward but he never mentioned that
it's kind of a canary in the coal mine
to remind you whether or not this is
still something that you probably need
to work on because if you get yourself
to the stage where you've completely
ameliorated whatever the regret
situation was and you've just brought it
imbibed it into your life
the regret would by design would start
to fall away maybe there would sort of
be some something that lingered but it
wouldn't be visceral and emotional in
the same way i don't think
so yeah that's
that's an interesting one i think pain
only really exists as a sort of warning
system to prevent you from
you know doing stupid things um like you
know for instance burning yourself you
know that's obviously the body's trying
to tell you don't put your hand in fire
you know and it's the same with
psychological pain as well if you if you
suffer as a result of something it's
your body's your way of telling you not
to do that don't do that because this is
going to be the effect
and
i think that the kind of fading effect
bias is your body's way of telling you
that this pain is nothing personal you
know it's just it's just there as a
lesson sort of thing you know don't take
it personally
and uh that's why we can kind of try and
see through it after a while and just be
like okay just needed to teach us a
lesson it was our boss in a way just
telling us look that's not the right way
to do it this is a way to do it now
let's go out for a drink and have a
point you know so it's like
it's it's it's just a kind of way of
just teaching us without you know any
any sort of hard feelings as it were
naval's razor if you can't decide
between two choices take the path that's
more difficult or painful in the short
term doing this will counteract the
hyperbolic discounting the brain's
tendency to overestimate short-term pain
and underestimate long-term pain
yeah so
we um
we perceive objects in time similarly to
how we perceive them through space
so the further something away is in
space
the smaller it appears and the same is
also true of time as well the further
something into the future something is
the less it really registers in our in
our lives and it's the same thing with
this further into the past
um
this you know obviously is a necessary
thing we have to focus on the present
moment because if we're too focused on
what's happening 10 years in the future
we're not going to be able to live our
lives
but it comes with side effects in that
we tend to
underestimate
uh problems in the future or even
rewards in the future
and we tend to overestimate problems and
rewards in the present
and this is why you know we tend to have
this kind of short-termist view of
things where
it makes this is why we procrastinate
essentially because we just passed the
book to you know we're like oh my future
self will deal with it you know
because your future self seems like it
can solve every problem in the world
because he seems like a superhero jeremy
because you don't need to think too far
ahead you don't think about your future
self very much just be like yeah he'll
sort out
i'm just going to focus on just eating
some ice cream and watching tv or
whatever you know
um
but
yeah this is i think this is one of the
things that really screws people over is
this sort of belief that
um
what's happening now is more important
always than what's happening in the
future
and it you know yeah to a certain extent
it is you've got to obviously be aware
of what's going on in the present but
you've got to always remember that your
brain is
configured to make you believe this and
so you have to take
the sort of opposite view i mean like
all biases now that we have now they're
all a result of heuristics like they're
all mental shortcuts that we once had in
a different environment and now they've
become
biases because we're in a completely
different environment but we can use
heuristics we can use a new set of
heuristics to overcome the present
biases that we have and one of these is
naval's uh razer naval ravicon he's a
great thinker i'm sure you know who he
is and probably most of the audience
know but yeah he's an investor and he's
a philosopher as well and um this is
just i think a great sort of
mental model to use
when you want to consider whether you
should pursue a certain action
you'll always underestimate the things
that are going to be happening
further out in the future
than you will the things that are
happening closer to the present so
therefore always take this into account
when you're making decisions you know
because
your brain is very good at making you
believe that the only thing that matters
is the present
there's a thing that i brought science
called anxiety cost which is the longer
that you take to complete an action the
more time that is taken up thinking
about having not completed the action
yeah so you wake up every morning you've
got to meditate you've got to go to the
gym you've got to do whatever if you do
it in the morning then you've got the
rest of the day to enjoy it if you wait
until the evening time then you've spent
all of that time every single second
that your mind was taken up thinking
about the fact that you haven't
meditated or gone to the gym yet could
have got been gotten rid of had you have
done it in the morning that's the
anxiety cost and you can ameliorate that
in a similar way by getting things done
and i think if you can't decide between
two equal choices take the path that's
more difficult or painful in the short
term is basically you trying to start to
front load against that hyperbolic
discounting right it's it's reverse
procrastination okay if i try and find
something that seems overly difficult
short term that probably will maybe end
up being about equal to what it should
be rationally over the long term
yeah absolutely yeah yeah i think um
it's it's hard to really because you
can't quantify
value in in very sort of accurate ways
when it comes to whether i should do a
certain action or another one you can't
put numbers on it but as a sort of just
general rule of thumb it's always worth
considering that you're always going to
overestimate um the short term
over the long term you know what you
have to do in the short term over the
long term because the long term
is something that you don't want to
think about most of the time you know
and so um yeah
absolutely it's uh it's an important um
it's an important way to sort of uh
defeat procrastination i think because
at the end of the day
postponing a problem extends it as you
said you know
so
the best thing to do is just to get it
done as quick as possible and then you
have more time to just
do whatever you want want to do you know
it's more
that's [ __ ] lovely postponing a
problem extends it that is absolutely
lovely right next one so pose law i got
taught about by my housemate a couple of
weeks ago
uh but
i i'd seen it written online and people
had said it but i never actually
bothered to look at the definition of it
which i guess is probably most people
with most things um poe's law it's now
impossible to distinguish trolling from
sincerity online partly because [ __ ]
posts have become so lifelike and partly
because life has become so [ __ ]
post-like
yeah
i mean what else is there to say i mean
yeah
i think everybody knows this you know
when you when you go on social media um
it's just impossible to tell whether
somebody's serious whether somebody's
actually saying
whether somebody actually believes what
they're saying um
and i think you know this is
largely i think this is a result of
the sort of short format of um of social
media in that you know you never really
get context
in in on social media you just kind of
just get a short snippet of what
somebody's saying but you don't
understand sort of what led to that
thought process you don't understand the
motivations or the intent behind it you
can always gauge if you look at a book
if you read a book within a few pages
you'll be able to understand what the
author's trying to convince you of and
you know you'll understand a bit more
about the author's background and things
like that just without them telling you
directly just from what they they write
you can't really do that with social
media you can only see just an isolated
just a couple of sentences or just a
meme that somebody's posted you know and
that so basically all the information
you're getting on on social media most
of it at least is anonymous it's it's
coming from people who you have
absolutely no idea what their intentions
are what their motivations are and this
problem is compounded by the fact that
we have now massive amounts of um
manipulators online we've got troll
farms we've got marketers
we've got um
culture warriors we've got all these
different people who are all you know
just trying to manipulate the
information space
and so they're putting out stuff
sometimes that they think is false you
know
they'll create a
um an account you know of like
maga mike or something and then they'll
start posting you know like loads of
pro trump stuff you know
and there's loads of these sort of fake
accounts um that are kind of just
flooding social media and
a lot of it's just really outrageous
stuff you know like trump is the son of
god and he's gonna you know bring about
the second coming and stuff and
you know that there are people on this
earth who are crazy enough to believe
[ __ ] like that so you can't discount it
as just
just satire a parody or just some
attempt to you know um to just
screw with people's heads but the place
that these people have to retreat to if
they do say something which is beyond
the pale or outside the overton window
or completely unacceptable or whatever
is it was just a joke bro that's the the
defense mechanism that most people fall
back on this has always been
the um
a
point of envy that i've had over
comedian podcasters because they can
always say anything and use the
i'm just a comedian
yeah as an excuse it's the get out of
jail free card he said something that
was i mean if anyone's listened to
andrew schultz's intros recently he does
i don't know whether he's done it on his
most recent episodes but certainly when
he first started his new studio he does
kind of a bit maybe a 30 second to a one
minute bit which is a little bit like
the old saturday night style so tonight
we've got coming up into this thing you
know this thing except for the fact that
it is the most ruthless cutting jokes
that you can think of about anyone that
they're maybe going to bring up or stuff
that's happened in the past or whatever
and i keep on thinking
how
the living [ __ ] does this guy get away
with saying that on the internet without
being cancelled like just outrageous
stuff but because it's delivered well
and because it's evidently a joke
there are different rules so if you can
accept the fact that there are different
rules for jokes than things that people
say seriously what you have with poe's
law is basically a way for people to
push the variance and the boundaries of
what they typically say
while using the it's maybe just a joke
bro card as a an ejector seat that they
can pull if they need it absolutely yeah
yeah i think this is spot on i think a
lot of people i've seen this happen as
well on social media where a lot of
people
will say this and they'll use it and
they'll use it as a get out of jail card
basically if you point out that what
they've said is stupid they can always
just say oh i'm only joking bro you know
yeah it's something they're trying to
make you look like the idiot for having
not got the joke that wasn't it
yeah you threw
something out there that had it have
landed as a genuine insight you would
have happily taken that road and you
threw something else the same thing and
how if it gets lambasted and you need to
call it a joke then so be it it's kind
of unfalsifiable in a way
yeah absolutely it gives them plausible
deniability at all times so they can
just say whatever they like and get away
with it you know like they'll be
anything that that is taken seriously
and is like you know appreciated they'll
be like yeah that's what i really mean
but everything that's not i didn't mean
that you know i'm just joking so you
know it's like
yeah so it's a very clever very uh
digital sort of digital defense
mechanism
so
i
on rogan the the biggest insight that i
learned when i went on his show i've
given a name to so it's rogan's
difficulty and value conflation
so this is from my three-minute monday
newsletter so some people may be
familiar with this already but i really
loved it this is a quote from him quote
look at the car he's driving look at the
watch he's wearing look at the girl he's
with that's so unattainable to many
people so it seems like it's valuable
but then you attain it and then you
realize oh this is not valuable this is
just difficult to get and there's a
difference there's a big difference yeah
some things aren't valuable they're just
difficult to get in a world which has
never been more convenient our ability
to avoid discomfort is very high it
means we can sail through life in a
chasm of comfortable complacency most
smart people also realize that there is
value in stepping outside of this
comfort that on the other side of the
discomfort is something valuable we're
told that worthwhile things are
difficult to attain because if they
weren't difficult to attain they
wouldn't be worthwhile this is how
non-valuable but difficult things get
slipped into our desires without just
noticing attaining something worthwhile
is often going to be difficult but just
because it's difficult doesn't mean it's
worthwhile we use the challenge as a
proxy for virtue or value or alignment
or integrity there's some signaling
going on here too difficult things by
design will be attained by a small
number of people which makes them
desirable simply because it's an easy
way to stand out from the crowd we
realized too that sometimes easiness can
be a signal of value in my opinion
valuable relationship shouldn't be hard
your partner should be someone you would
take to wall or take into war not
someone you're at war with your friends
should make your life better not more
difficult your parents should make you
feel enough not insufficient valuable
work on the other hand is a beautiful
blend of difficulty in ease an apple
employee once asked tim cook about
whether it should still feel like hard
work when you do something you love tim
replied you'll have to work harder than
you ever have in your before in your
life but the tools will feel light in
your hands beware the difficult things
masquerading as the valuable ones
perfect yeah absolutely yeah i was a big
fan actually of your your brogan podcast
i remember that line as well thank you
um
yeah and i think that this is actually
this explains a lot
of the sort of incentive structures that
we see in the world today um for example
i'll give you an example of this um i
used to be quite addicted to video games
and um one of the things i i used to
play was a game called diablo 3.
it's basically you run around just
killing zombies and demons and stuff
like that and um
and what they did is they basically had
this concept called loot boxes and this
is something that you've probably heard
about since then because i think diablo
3 was the first one that really did this
um there were like loot boxes which you
could
obtain
but they made these loot boxes extremely
difficult to get
and and the reason that they did it i
think
is to make them valuable
um for no other reason than just to make
them valuable because a lot of these um
i remember like the actual things
themselves weren't that great like um
they were they were legendary weapons
for instance that you could get and
these weapons would be like a bit more
they could have bonus effects like for
instance they would freeze enemies if
you hit them with the sword you know
like an eyesore or whatever um and they
would have these bonus effects but they
wouldn't actually be that powerful they
would just be extremely hard to get so
that when people did get them to get a
sense of achievement and it would create
like a dopamine reward in their in their
brain they'd be like oh my god i've got
this swords rare sword and even though
it's just a piece of crap you know and
you will eventually you'll need another
better weapon as the levels progress you
know because this weapon isn't gonna
isn't gonna cut it literally you know
and so um you know you basically uh kind
of you're in this
loop where you're constantly looking for
the next legendary weapon legendary
weapons drop like once every
200 enemies or something you have to
kill about 200 enemies and then you then
it drops the treasure box and then in
that treasure box you'll get this thing
that glows and it's like a legendary
weapon so
they would make these really really hard
to get and after a while there were a
lot of complaints i think there was even
talk of a class-action lawsuit because
they were making people um buy these um
weapons you know people because it's it
takes so much time just to get one of
these weapons that people just fork out
money instead but the weapons wouldn't
last very long so you wouldn't get that
effect very long and if they were
milking it they were making so much
money and this was the thing that
kick-started this whole
loot box thing if you if you know
anything about video games you'll know
about loot boxes it's a very
manipulative practice that is used
in video games and i think i mean
i'm not really sure that they that you
could apply it to something like social
media
um but there is a certain
difficulty in acquiring a large follower
follow account and getting that kind of
social approval and i think
one of the reasons why people value that
so much is because of the amount of
effort that you have to put into it it's
not really that special to have
a large number of followers because it's
anybody can do if you've got enough time
um you don't actually even have to be an
interesting person you can just just
talk [ __ ] and you'll you'll get your
everybody grows an audience over time
yes um you know you just have to look at
some of the people who have audiences to
see that you don't need any special
skill to be you just need to labor away
and just post consistently
and so it creates this kind of
this
sort of sense that yeah if you've got a
lot of followers that you're a special
person but you're not really all you've
done is just posted consistently over
a period of years
it's kind of a little bit like
goodheart's law right when a measure
becomes an outcome it ceases to be a
good measure that people use follow
account as a proxy for
value or integrity or insight or
whatever entertainment whatever it is
that people are following these people
for did you ever find when you were
playing diablo 3 that you would use a
sub-optimal web weapon that signaled
um difficulty ahead of a more effective
weapon that would be more valuable
i can't say i did but i think uh there
probably were other people who do you
understand the dynamic though right the
fact that you want to swing you want to
swing the cool sword that doesn't do
much damage rather than the effective
sword that doesn't look so good
i mean i i didn't say it with diablo 3
but i do remember seeing it with um with
street fighter that was another game
that used to play street fighter
i think it was street fighter 3 right um
because there's this character on street
fighter called dan
and he's got a pink um sort of a pink uh
what they called uh the overalls they
were forgot what they're called um but
he basically he was like a ryu like and
a ken kind of character except he was
pink instead of white or red and he was
deliberately really weak like the guys
capcom who made the game they made him
deliberately weak as a kind of handicap
to um you know just so that people who
are really good at the game they could
basically beat somebody with dan and
just humiliate them basically
okay yeah that's very funny yeah yeah
yeah
and so there were there were people who
would do this and some people would
actually take dan to these tournaments
as well like there's these big
tournaments in street fighter where you
can earn like hundreds of thousands of
dollars and people some people were so
cocky they would actually take dan and
they would play as dan in these
tournaments these world tournaments with
some of the best players
most of them would get their asses
kicked but i mean if you would see like
exhibition games against less skilled
players where dan would just completely
wipe the floor with you know like ryu or
one of the others
thing does happen yeah um yeah all right
nova effect you may think losing your
job is bad but what if staying at your
job would have led to you dying in a
fire you can't truly know if an outcome
is good or bad because fortune can lead
to misfortune and vice versa so don't be
quick to judge the cards you're dealt
yeah so
the thing with outcomes is that outcomes
never end
every outcome has another outcome
you know so
if
if if something happens then that's
going to cause other things to happen
and then that thing's going to cause
other things to happen and it's a chain
that's just going to continue forever
into the future so
when you actually zoom out of the
present moment and you actually look at
the entire span of your life
or even just you know
it could just be a year it doesn't even
have to be that long you can see that
fortunes change very quickly
what seemed to be an advantage to you is
now a disadvantage or what seemed to be
a disadvantage is now an advantage and
there's an old chinese proverb about
this
um called good look bad luck it's a long
story and it's about um basically just
about a story of
how um
you know a guy gets uh
he gets thrown off his horse and he
breaks his leg and he thinks it's bad
luck
but then what happens is that some uh
soldiers come to his village and they
they ask him to
ask for conscription in the army because
they want to fight some war and because
he's got a broken leg he doesn't have to
go to the into the war so
what was
initially a bad
accident has turned out to be fortuitous
to him
and i think this is something that
people don't appreciate enough because
we tend to just look at a single outcome
and just be like oh that's a bad thing
but we don't look at the effects of the
effects and this is obviously
links into second order thinking
um you know the idea that we should
consider the consequences of
consequences and not just the
consequences
and so i think people really need to
take them zoom out and just take a wider
look at things and try not to be too
hasty in judging things as good or bad
it's this is something that i suffer
from myself i think it's instinctive in
us all where we all are quick to judge
something good or quick to do something
bad but i think when we take a longer
longer term view of things we start to
realize that um
you know that there's this kind of
dynamic of
oscillation of things that will be good
one moment and they'll become bad and
they'll become good and they'll become
bad and i think that if you remember
this it can help you to
not be
not be crushed by bad events in your
life and
and likewise not be
not be so of not let good things go to
your head and make you cocky and yes
yeah i think this links in nicely with
the fading affect bias as well right
just the hyperbolic discounting thinking
long term so there's something here that
i've been thinking about for ages about
what happens in reverse about the
stories that we tell ourselves about
when bad or good things happen to us i
always got irritated for ages and i
couldn't work out why
when people said
um it was meant to be
so something bad occurs and then a
situation
ends up spiraling around and then they
end up in a better place they go you
know i lost my job but that meant that i
met my partner because while i was doing
training or art class or whatever that i
wouldn't have been able to go through
and i think the reason that i don't like
that type of
um
narrative is that it's incredibly
disempowering to the agency of the
individual over them to take a bad
situation and turn it good
why would you attribute
the success that the situation has had
from something sub-optimal to something
optimal
to anything that isn't you
like why not take credit for it people
want to take credit for almost
everything but for some reason in these
situations looking in retrospect to a
bad situation a lot of the time people
will claim that the outcome was some
mystical
it was meant to be force and it seems
like it's related to what we're talking
about here the nova effect but but in
reverse
yeah absolutely
um
i think this kind of segues um quite
well into
the concept of the region beta paradox
yes there he is
so you know like so circumstances can
sometimes drive us to
be better than we are you know so if we
are in a sort of
really really bad situation if we um
i mean you use this example when you
when you gave the example you basically
spoke of how if something is a certain
distance from you um your your walk the
distance you know but then if
something's just a tiny bit further away
then you'll think oh okay i might as
well just drive the way there you know
so that that tiny change in the
environment
is causing a completely different
outcome in your behavior
and
this is how i think negative
events in your life can actually turn
you it can actually be turned to your
fortune they can actually make you into
a better person because if you're under
discomfort
that can drive you to to be better and
to do things that you want to do in life
rather than
if you're comfortable and i think that
this is something another thing that
people underestimate is that
the discomforts that occur in our lives
make us stronger overall they make us go
out there and do things
um they make us think about they make us
think outside the box
you know if you are comfortable your
whole life if you have everything given
to you
that's not actually a good outcome even
though you might think it is it's not a
good outcome because what's happening is
that your your brain and your body is
going to be atrophying
because you're not using it you don't
need to use it because you're
comfortable it's only when you're not
comfortable that you begin to think and
begin to actually do things and this is
when you think outside the box
so if
a bad event occurs in your life
there are two ways of looking at it you
can either feel sorry for yourself and
say oh you know this is horrible you
know um
what what's the point you know what's
the point doing and when fate's just
going to throw in my back in my face or
you can use it and say okay this is a
problem i need to solve it and then you
start solving it and in solving it you
actually benefit from that bad event yes
so that's like alchemy that's like yeah
psychological alchemy absolutely yeah
you turn you turn the lead that would
weigh you down
into gold you know so it's um
yeah this is this is a form of
of this kind of oscillation that i was
talking about you know you you take
something bad and then you turn into
something good and so you get
the trough of experience and you turn
into the peak of experience you become
better through adversity and so this is
another reason not to believe that bad
things that happen to you are
are bad because they they drive you to
be better than you actually are i think
this is one of the the sort of defining
philosophies of stoicism which i
recently released a um
an article about i knew also i think you
had
a guest on talking about stoicism quite
recently as well yes and this is why
stoicism i think is such a powerful
philosophy and why it's so widespread in
places like silicon valley and wall
street it's because
it allows you to turn
stress and misfortune and things like
that
negative things that would ordinarily be
considered negative and to turn them
into
empowering
actions you know to actually make the
most of them and and to actually become
better as a result of them so you turn
misfortune into force into fortune which
i think is a one of the most powerful
things you can do invincible i never
realized that amor fatty wasn't
stoic it's nietzsche right
well it the idea originates with the
stoics nietzsche sort of appropriated it
from the stoics a little bit even though
he he despised the stoics because he he
misunderstood what they meant by living
according to nature but he
he did still read a lot of stoicism and
he um he took this idea and he made it
his i mean
the idea is more famously associated
with nietzsche but it actually
originates with um i think it originates
with seneca
uh as far as we know anyway it probably
precedes seneca to someone like
clianthis or chrysippus but we don't
know about their thought very much
because not much of their work survives
so the first i think
known incident of this is thinking the
work of seneca in which he talks about
how
you know people think that amor fati
means that you should just be resigned
to fate that you should just allow
whatever happens to happen and just be
passive and this is couldn't be further
from the truth it's not about being
passive
it's about
understanding the difference between
what you can control and what you can't
control and focusing your energies on
what you can control and just accepting
the things you can't control because if
you don't accept things you can't
control you can't focus on the things
that you can control so you're not
living optimally you're not constantly
going to be fighting against that which
can't be changed exactly it's like
trying to swim against the tide you know
you're just you're wasting your energy
you're just you and you're going nowhere
so
you what you got to do is you've got to
surf that tide you know ride it no
matter how where it takes you ride that
tide because you can't do anything about
it
but what you can do is you can control
how you surf
you know you can control your balance
you can control
your positioning of your feet on the
board the story that you tell yourself
about the waves that you're on top of
yeah that that's one thing that you can
definitely
do something about but most of all is is
your actions
your actions are what you have complete
control over
and
your actions
are the things that ultimately determine
your fate
because it's not like as epic ted teddy
said it's not what happens to you it's
how you react to it that matters
um because
you know we're all going to die one day
when we're all you know we're all aging
we're all wrong slowly decaying we can't
do anything about that so there's no
point in getting upset about it what we
can do about is that we can we could be
healthy we can live healthy lives we can
make the most of the time that we're on
this planet and so drawing a distinction
between the things we can't control and
things we can't is very important
because it allows you to direct your
energies towards the areas where you can
actually make an impact and that's what
animal fatigue is it's about result it's
about essentially
accepting the things you can't change
because
not accepting them is not going to
matter it's not going to change anything
it's not gonna you know it's just uh
it's like being upset that you're gonna
die it's not gonna change anything it's
not gonna change the fact that you're
gonna die you're still gonna die so you
have to focus on what you can do
something about and i think that's uh
yeah that's the essence of
what i really liked about the region
beta paradox which is another uh adam
mastroianni i'm going to link his stuff
in the show notes because i've butchered
his name so much
um
yeah what the example was if you have a
rule that you walk whenever you're
traveling a mile or less or you drive
when you're traveling more than a mile
then paradoxically you get two miles
faster than you get one mile the
important insight here is if you only
take action when things cross a certain
threshold of badness sometimes better
things can feel worse than worse things
and this is i had i think it's episode
13 or something with a friend of mine
guy called michael cashew and he was a
drug addict from the age of 11 or 12
heroine by 13 or 14 and then by the age
of 22 23
he was two times crossfit games a kill
affiliate cup champion in the team and
then they started a multi-million pound
business and then married a woman who
started another multi-million pound
business with him and he now lives here
in austin they've got this beautiful kid
and another one on the way and blah blah
blah and even at the time i remember
using this example about the fact anyone
that's ever tried to squat something
very heavy but you've only done a
three-quarter squat
it's actually easier to bounce out of
the bottom because you get a little bit
of elasticity from the bottom of your
squat than it is to take it just a bit
above that and then have to drive it up
yourself and it's kind of the same here
if you don't act until you cross a
particular threshold of badness you get
stuck in region beta and region beta is
comfortable complacency right it's the
job which is pretty crap but maybe has
good benefits and you don't have to do
much or it's the relationship which
isn't bad and traumatic but it isn't
that good either or it's the flat which
you know is pretty terrible to live in
and has a bit of mold but not that much
mold and maybe it's cheap and in an
alright location or something if any of
these situations got a little worse you
would have the activation energy to get
yourself out of them and to move on to
something else and this is i think i
mean talib's got that barbell strategy
thing right where the gray zone is where
you go to die you want to be in black
and white and it kind of gets reflected
here as well that
if something's unbelievably good then
fantastic keep it going if something's
unbelievably bad then you'll be
motivated to change it if something's
just about comfortably numb enough in
the middle
that's that is precisely where you can
spend
decades
yeah in complacency
yeah so someone said i've forgotten who
who they were but they said that
life begins at the end of your comfort
zone
and i think that's so true i think um
when you test yourself when you put
yourself in situations where you're not
comfortable that's when you actually
begin to really feel alive and that's
when you tend to actually begin to make
the most of who you are your brain works
faster because you're you're thinking
about
unfamiliar
surroundings you're thinking about an
unfilling a familiar environment
it's it's when you know for instance
when you go to sleep in a new place
uh your brain half of your brain
actually stays awake
uh because you have more micro
awakenings because it's uncertain about
whether it's safe or not yeah yeah yeah
and your brain is more active when
you're in a completely new environment
than when you're in the same environment
over and over again
and so really
you what your brain really needs to
develop is it needs to be uncomfortable
it needs to be in a situation that you
don't that you can't predict
one where you're unfamiliar with what's
with what the rules of the game are
so i think that this really applies a
lot to life is that if you i think one
of the sort of dangers of of the world
that we're living in at the moment is
that everything is just so easy
in terms of compared to how it used to
be well think about it this way we're
going out of our way to artificially
inject difficulty into our lives yeah
i've got a cold i've got a cold plunge
tub outside i have to i have to go and
buy
a purpose-built piece of equipment
to set outside in my yard to get into it
for three minutes
whatever times a day and then get out
and do breath work and all this stuff
because i'm going from air-conditioned
room to air-conditioned room to shade
covered veranda you know like
yeah i mean um yeah like ted kaczynski
the uh the unabomber
uh i mean his his uh his work the
industrial society and his future is a
pretty crazy uh sort of expose in a way
of the sort of world that we're living
in now
um even though it was written in the
1980s and um
he basically talked to this thing called
um surrogate
activities which is basically the idea
that our lives have become so
comfortable that we have to artificially
create struggles
and you know the examples i think he
gives are things like sports
and um
you could apply also to video games
culture wars online
even like just politics itself a lot of
that is just sort of theater you know we
create these kind of artificial
struggles just so that we feel alive
because that's because the brain is a
problem-solving machine
and
when it finds itself without problems it
invents the problem
to solve itself so that it has so it can
solve the problem of having no problems
to solve you know
um it's basically you know that this is
the brain the brain is a problem-solving
machine that's why it exists it exists
to solve problems that's the
evolutionary function of the brain and
so when we find ourselves in an
environment in which we have very few
problems
where you know we can instantly eat food
just by picking up the phone and just
calling someone and they'll deliver it
to our doorstep or you know uh if we
are
cold we could just take a hot shower or
you know there's this this this life is
just so much easier now than it was in
the past and problems most of the
problems in our lives have very easy
solutions you know if we have a headache
we can just take an aspirin you know if
we
if we are feeling like
something strange in our belly we can
just google the problem online
things are getting easier and easier and
so the brain
is finding itself
is finding it necessary to create more
and more of these surrogate activities
and i think this is one reason why the
culture wars have just been taken over
online on places like twitter
because people feel the need to have
this struggle they feel the need to rage
against something even if it's a um
self-created enemy shadow boxing and
imaginary hegemon yeah absolutely i mean
i think sports i think this is what
sports is in a sense is that this kind
of sense of competition and not just the
competitors themselves but the teams and
the people who support the team attend
war
yeah it's pretend well i mean that's
essentially what especially in the uk
like football hooliganism you know you
see i mean i used to live in luton and i
lived right next door to the states the
stadium every saturday night it was
absolutely crazy you know yeah yeah the
migs who were these hooligans basically
they just get pissed up at the um local
tavern and they're just basically just
start parading through the streets and
just you know just screaming at everyone
and just egging themselves on and just
trying to get themselves ready it was
like the war paint on as well you know
and they're just basically it was like
they're going to war basically that's
what it was like every saturday and i
just i remember looking at them just
thinking
these guys are identical to the sort of
the tribes that existed a hundred
thousand years ago you know who would
put on their war paint and just go to
war you know this is exactly the same
dynamic that it's this activistic sort
of element of this tribal behavior
that's re-manifesting in their lives
and it happens just so often people want
struggle in their lives and i think
culture war is
is the next evolution of this it's an
online video game that everybody plugs
into like when they go on twitter and
they you know they come across this kind
of
battle this virtual battlefield where
you know their their side is on this
right side of history and they're gonna
they're gonna defeat the enemies of
humanity and then they're gonna be
remembered as the heroes of humanity by
all the sort of proceeding proceeding
generations you know all of posterity um
but i mean
it's all it's all an illusion that the
brain conjures in order to
justify its own existence because if the
brain has no problems
to solve what happens you get bored
that's what boredom is you know boredom
is when your brain is not fulfilling its
evolutionary purpose when it's not
solving problems
um or when it's not engaged in
analysis well we saw we saw probably a
good example of this at the very
beginning of the pandemic so the
the brief two-week period where
everybody came together before it was
politicized yeah and what you saw was
i know in the presence of a real crisis
everybody re-centered our values but in
the absence of a real crisis we created
our own
and it feels very much like uh
that was a an example of what humanity
could get to if everybody was facing a
little bit of discomfort on a daily
basis because everybody did face a
little bit of discomfort there was some
uncertainty there was a requirement for
everybody to bind together and then very
very quickly everyone was like we're
probably going to be okay therefore what
is the next problem that i can manifest
in order to solve right this next one uh
apothea is that how i say it yeah up
there yeah apithea often fear is more
crippling than that which is feared rage
is more maddening than that which
enrages hate is more toxic than that
which is hated few foes crush us more
than our emotions so victory over our
enemies requires victory over our
feelings about them
yeah so this is another core concept in
stoicism
and
this is
i think something that's extremely
relevant today because
we are essentially we're over stimulated
in in the in the digital age you know
we're just being barraged with stimuli
and these stimuli are making us feel
emotions
and that they're calculated to make us
feel emotions as well they're actually
that's the reason that we're being
bombarded with this stimuli is to
basically just
make us feel and these feelings then
drive our behaviors in ways that are
beneficial to the people that are
bombarding us with the stimuli
um so
you know
one example would be um
the sort of dopamine rush that we get
from
being you know approval on social media
getting approval on social media that's
whole the whole system is set up in a
way as to make us chase social approval
um we want more followers we want more
engagement with our posts and so we we
seek out to do that you know we we're
rats in the skinner box we're basically
pulling that lever to get that pellet
that food pellet
and um this is it's not just with with
this emotion it's with pretty much every
emotion that we can possibly feel if you
look at anxiety um
they make us anxious like the news the
news uh
agencies they make us anxious because
they want us to be fearful because if
we're fearful we're going to want to
read more articles about the thing
that's we're scared of so if they make
us fearful of terrorism then we're going
to read more articles about terrorism
because we're going to be worried so
we're going to want to know
what's going on and so they're going to
get more income because they're going to
get more page views so it works out for
them so it's in their interest to make
us anxious and then outrage is also
another classic example
if you make people angry then they're
gonna complain about it on twitter
they're gonna spread their outrage to
other people
and we all know that outrage spreads
like wildfire you know online
and it's one of the most consistent ways
that you can get attention and get your
message out there is just by outraging
people so now we have um things called
ragebay
and even the new york times you know the
old
sort of bastions of journalistic
integrity and they are engaging in this
sort of stuff now as well where what
they'll do is they'll say something that
they know is stupid so it'll be
something like um you know i mean i'm
just gonna make something up but this is
the kind of thing that i post something
like um refrigerators are an expression
of white supremacy or something like
that you know
um you know tvs are racist or whatever
you know they'll just get a random
object and call it you know racist and
they do that on purpose i don't think
that they're stupid enough to actually
believe what they're writing but they're
doing it because they know that it's
going to anger
their enemies it's going to anger people
in the republican party it's going to
anger the anti-sjw
the retweet of somebody that agrees with
you is worth precisely the same as the
retweet of somebody that doesn't in fact
it might be worth even more i think i
saw an uh
a map of you showing just how bifurcated
online communication is between left and
right so what you're actually optimizing
for maybe in order to reach new viewers
is to get people who typically wouldn't
engage with your content to engage with
your content which probably means people
on the other side not the same site
that's a very good way a good point
actually yeah and i think that's
probably that that figures into the sort
of calculations um i think
with the with the sort of these kinds of
uh these divisive articles um
i mean like scott alexander the uh the
bay area psychiatrist
he he spoke of scissor statements which
are statements that are supposed to make
people angry and to make them take a
strong stance
on on you know one of the issues so for
instance you could say something like
trans women are women you post that you
know that's just going to settle
fireworks you know because there's going
to be some people who agree with it and
they're going to agree with it very
strongly and they're going to be people
who disagree with it and they're going
to be they're going to think about it
very strongly so these two groups are
going to argue with each other and in
arguing with each other they're going to
spread the idea they're going to spread
it across
all domains and so
this is this is the the interesting
thing that he found is that
it's actually the things that divide
people that spread furthest not the
things that people agree with not the
things that everybody agrees with was
that the the toxoplasma of rage was that
that yes this is this is it yeah this is
exactly what he called it so i think we
did cover this on a previous episode but
this this is essentially what it is it's
um that that ideas that unified people
don't spread as far as ideas that divide
people and so this is why we have rage
bay this is it's a business decision you
know it's to basically spread the ideas
not just in the in
in the circle of the new york times
readers but also in the rival
gang in the sort of right-wing sort of
groups so
so all these emotions that we're feeling
they're all
they're all sort of promoted by the
online ecosystem anxiety you know anger
desire um even happiness you know all
these feelings that that that
artificially sort of almost inserted
into our brains
uh just to make us to control us
and so the stoic idea that the emotions
causes more harm than the things that
that caused them is actually very apt i
think it's more relevant now
even now than it was in ancient greece
when the idea was first formulated and
which is why i posted the idea because
these emotions are used to control us
you know if you are sort of
easily outraged then you're easily
manipulated
uh if you're
you know sort of
any any emotion that you feel will be
used
to control you basically so um
epic tennis has this great
line where he says
anyone capable of angering you becomes
your master
because they're essentially what they're
doing is they're getting your attention
and they're redirecting your attention
in to where they want it to be
and they're making you dance like a
monkey essentially they're just making
you move and they're making you act in
ways that you don't necessarily want to
but which you can't control because your
emotions are overpowering you so i think
it's very important that we control our
emotions in this digital age because
those emotions are used to manipulate us
and to control us more than they ever
have throughout history
sam harris has a really interesting
insight here where he talks about um
try and be angry without maintaining
your anger the point being that the the
sensation of whatever made you angry is
super super brief and almost all of the
area under the curve of your anger for
the rest of time is you perpetuating
some story or framework or narrative or
little mantra about how you could would
should have changed what that person
would have done to you and it's you that
ends up becoming
your own mind
has caused way more suffering than
whatever occurred in the first instance
that's the the pebble that caused the
avalanche perhaps but it's you that
perpetuates it there's another thing
another thing here as well which i think
is very interesting that if you look at
it from the other side should be quite
reassuring to most people which is that
your own mind is able to torture you in
significantly more sophisticated ways
than anything or anybody that's outside
of you and this is one thing for anyone
that's gone through depression or low
mood periods anxiety and stuff which you
know we all have some more than others
if that's been you
you can
find firm ground and reassurance in the
fact that there is very little out there
in the world that can hurt you as much
as your own mind already has yeah
absolutely yeah yeah that's a great way
of looking at it i think um
what i tend to
do with emotions is it's impossible to
not feel emotions you can't just stop
yourself from feeling emotions but what
you can do is you can you can develop
some distance between yourself and your
emotions and that's what i try to do is
that when i feel an emotion i don't
automatically react i i put a gate
between stimulus and response um so
when i feel that that anger or whatever
what i do is i i use it as information
that's what emotions are to me emotions
are information
it's your body's way of telling you that
something has
upset or provoked your evolutionary
ancestors not you but your ancestors
your distant distant ancestors
so if somebody you know somebody angers
you that's basically your ancient
ancestor telling you that a line has
been crossed
but whether you actually choose to
believe that is up to you because you're
living in a completely different world
to the world of your ancestors you know
they lived in tribes they lived out in
the on savannah or in the jungle you
know so they had a completely different
environment so the things that they
might think were lines that were crossed
may not be like what you think is a line
that was crossed so you use it as
information you use your emotions as
advisers not as masters
you know never be controlled by emotions
but understand that they're telling you
something about about the present
environment so if somebody's angered you
what does that really mean what does it
actually mean you know i try to look at
you know what does this actually mean
when somebody angers me what's actually
happening there and it's basically
if you go back to the evolutionary
history
we needed a way to enforce boundaries
before we had police before we had you
know a legal system
there needed to be some sort of way of
reinforcing our own personal boundaries
or even the tribe's boundaries
and anger became a way to do that
because if you if there's a cost to
with screwing with somebody else
then obviously you're not going to want
to screw with that person if the cost is
that they might lose their mind for a
moment and pick up a spear and hurl it
at you you know
obviously you don't want to engage in
that behavior so it worked as a very
effective
sort of regulatory system before the
advent of police before the advent of
any legal system
and so that's carrying over now into
this world where we do have police we do
have a system of order we have a society
of morals and ethics and all this kind
of stuff that we've developed since
those times so it's become anger has in
a way become obsolete it's still not
completely obsolete because there are
times when you should be angry because
there are certain lines that that should
not be crossed and you know you should
reinforce those lines but most of the
things that you see online are not going
to be lines that you need to enforce if
you're you know somebody calls you you
know
a [ __ ] online you know it doesn't
matter it's not you don't need to get
angry about it because you're never
going to see this guy in your life
you're never going to you don't even
know who they are they could just be a
chatbot you know who
might not even be a real person so
there's no there's no need and you know
what is it it's just a word they've
literally just put a word on it on a
screen and that's it
you know so but people will they won't
think about these things they'll they
won't put that gate between stimulus and
response as soon as they see that word
as soon as they see that insult
you know the old ancestral sort of alarm
system kicks in and they start losing
their [ __ ]
so yeah definitely gotta
realize that it's just information
that's all it is it's all emotions are
just information
regret minimization somewhere in the
future your older self is watching you
through memories whether it's with
regret or nostalgia depends on what you
do now
yeah so this
is one that i sometimes use myself when
i feel that i'm not motivated to do
things i've always found that
a great way to develop
the sort of uh
a good character is to actually zoom out
of your life and to look at the whole
picture
and this is something that you know also
applies with the 10 10 10 strategy
so the 10 10 10 strategy i think we
might have mentioned before i don't know
but this is one of the mental models in
one of the mega threads i think that i
wrote
and basically it's the idea that
we can stop ourselves engaging in
behaviors that we might regret if we
think about
how we would
react to those behaviors in 10 minutes
in 10
months and in 10 years so let me give
examples so
let's say you're addicted to cigarettes
and you really want to quit cigarettes
you don't want to have a cigarette but
you're you've got an urge to just have
it one cigarette like our ridges just
one cigarette won't hurt
most of the time
it's very hard to
overcome that urge but what you can do
is you can zoom out of your life and
look at the whole the totality of your
life and say okay i'm here now
if i do have this cigarette
how will i feel about having that
cigarette
having had that cigarette in 10 minutes
how will i feel about it in 10 months
how will i feel about it in 10 years
and when you do that you realize that
it's actually not going to make much of
a difference to your life at all because
after you have smoked that cigarette at
like 10 minutes later
you don't feel any happier
you know i don't know if you've been
addicted to cigarettes but i was at one
point and it kind of
you don't feel happier when you smoke
you know it's just you feel like you
will be very happy if you could just
have that cigarette but once you've
actually got that cigarette in your
mouth and you're actually chugging on it
you don't feel happier
and after you've had it you certainly
don't feel happier you feel regret and
you just
gave in you feel weak and you feel like
you're giving in and that doesn't make
you feel good so
if you look at the long view look at
what your future self would think of
what you're doing
then that can help put things into
perspective and it can help you to
separate what's actually matters and
what doesn't matter and this is what i
mean when i say that your future self is
watching you through memories because if
you look at your future self as somebody
who already exists and they are
actually looking at you and in a way i
mean i'm a subscriber to the block
theory of the universe i do believe
that time that all times exist
that
when time is not a river that time is
actually an ocean and that all moments
exist forever but that our brains
because they're 3d we can only perceive
a moment at a time but i believe that
every moment of our lives is already
exist in existence right now um and i
think that
viewing things like that can help us to
take the long view and to see that hang
on a second
we're going to spend the rest of our
lives in the future so we should
actually care about that quite a bit you
know it's um
it's a lot more important than the
present moment which is just
literally gonna be gone like that i mean
does now even exist i mean
you know if i say now that's now in the
past
yeah and then now the now for you and
the now for me is ever so slightly
different in any case because of the
light cone right there is no such thing
it's already two as two separate nows
yeah well
one of the interesting things
to consider here when it comes to
considering what a life well lived means
for me a life well lived is one that in
retrospect you're glad you lived
and there's two views of happiness one
by dan gilbert and one by daniel
kahneman and they don't really agree
tremendously well so dan gilbert says if
you were to spend the rest of your life
on a lilo with a cocktail in a pool
just drinking and listening to tunes
that would be a life well-lived because
each individual now was one that was
filled with pleasure this is pleasure
this is pleasure this is pleasure and i
at first because that doesn't appeal to
me that's not the sort of thing that
would give me pleasure but i know that
there are people that it does i felt
like that was i don't know like a lesser
type of pleasure or something i got on
my high horse about how moral i was for
wanting the the more difficult
meaningful pleasure and daniel kahneman
says the opposite of something different
he says that you know a life well lived
a good life one that is happy is one
that in retrospect has given you meaning
that you're happy to look on in
retrospect the moment-to-moment
experience of it is less important than
the retrospective experience of it what
i've come to believe is that this is
dependent on how introspective you are
it'll align with stuff to do with
extraversion and introversion uh how
neurotic you are all sorts of different
personality biases and affects and stuff
but
if you're the sort of person that spends
a lot of time
um reflecting
doing internal work considering the way
that your life has been lived and
ruminating in a good way i guess or
being nostalgic
what you want to do is optimize your
life so that you have many different
memory slots filled with things that you
can be happy and proud of because things
that you've done in the past can give
you pleasure in the present in a way
that doing something like a lilo and a
cocktail can't that being said
i have a ton of friends that i know that
would [ __ ] love to just spend the
rest of time on a lilo with a cocktail
listening to tunes and throwing a ball
around with their friends and i would
happily go around to that party every so
often for me that wouldn't work for the
rest of time but there are people for
whom it does and i've come to believe
that the reason for that is that they
maybe are more forward thinking maybe
they're more present thinking maybe they
have you know
fewer uh neuroses to deal with than i do
i'm not sure but i think that that's an
interesting way to look at it right
absolutely yeah yeah that's a perfect
way of summing it up i mean i don't
think i could add anything i mean it's
just um it does yeah it does depend on
how introspective you are really because
how we live our lives is non-linear um
you know we don't live our lives just
straight through time
we live our lives darting to hopes to
the future then memories of the past
yeah we're constantly darting between
the future the present and the
past you know we're enjoying the sort of
present even when we're enjoying the
present we're sort of sometimes
just enjoying memories of the past
and so
i think yeah it does depend on the sort
of degree to which you you introspect
because people who introspect a lot
obviously are going to be darting around
through time a lot more and so the the
whole of their life is going to matter
more than just the present moment
but people who don't intersect very much
like ex extroverts yeah for them it's
just going to be party all the time you
know that's just living in the present
moment um but i mean there's an
interesting
thing which i've you know going back to
the whole point about does now even
exist i mean how long does now really
last i mean this is a question i've
always i actually have come to the
conclusion that now doesn't exist i
think
even when you're enjoying in the present
moment
what you're doing is that you're
enjoying something in the immediate past
uh like if you're even you know let's
say you're kissing someone um you're not
actually enjoying the present moment of
kissing you're actually enjoying
the the memory that you've created in
the immediate split second past of being
kissing that person and
the continuation of that in the future
it's not really the present moment
because even when you receive the nerve
impulses from kissing you you're
receiving them in in the in the past
yeah so sam sam harris has this
beautiful insight there's a
talk he gave called death in the present
moment it's about 10 or 15 years old
super super popular and there's an edit
of it uh i think it's maybe called on
life or something which he's got this
beautiful music underneath it anyway
he's talking about the fact that um our
conscious experience of the present
moment is in some very relevant sense
already a memory
and yeah
you know it becomes meaningful it only
becomes meaningful when it's a memory
yeah
once you've you can't consciously
process something before it's happened
that being said we're anticipatory
beings right
our entire
setup is designed to take ourselves out
of the present moment we anticipate
something before it happens we get
excited there's a good bit of evidence
that shows that people are actually they
enjoy experiences more in advance of
them happening than either during or
after they've happened and then once
something has occurred you have the
opportunity to reflect on it but yeah
right next one next one uh howard hughes
syndrome everyone always lies to the
powerful to curry favor or avoid
punishment hearing nothing but flattery
causes the most powerful people to
develop the most distorted views of
reality and their vast influence means
we all pay the price
yeah so i think this is a particular
problem of authoritarians um
people who
people are afraid of are only going to
hear stuff
that they want to hear you know
and if you look at history right
you look up history you find that every
dictator
ended up getting worse
and more unhinged through time i don't
know of any dictator who started off
extremely severe and um sane
sorry insane and then became less sane
over time they all went more unhinged
and they went more crazy and they became
more authoritarian over time
and i think part of the reason for that
is that
people
are so afraid of telling them the truth
that they just tell them what they want
to hear and they kind of cushion them in
this sort of
alternate reality in which they are god
and they can just everything is going
their way and it creates this it just
inflates their ego i mean you see it you
sorry with gaddafi you know qadhafi
actually started off as quite a sane
person you know he was he was just
basically wanted equality you know he
was like a kind of he was a socialist
and he just
uh you know he basically had the
socialist revolution and then over time
he began to develop this kind of per
this court personality but it wasn't
something that happened within a few
years or anything like this took decades
to really emerge and it happened very
gradually because as time went on people
became more and more afraid of telling
him the truth and so they began to
cocoon him in this kind of
web of lies where he was just hearing
only the things he wanted to hear and
this caused him to just gradually
distance himself from reality and he
became begun to believe that he was like
this grand god-like figure who was gonna
just bring you know the sort of justice
to the entire world he wanted to start
off this whole pan-african thing you
know and um his ambitions grew because
he he became so convinced of his own
godhood sort of anyway but he's one
example stalin is another example stalin
is a classic example by the end of his
life
by the end of stalin's life when he was
dying
nobody called the police it was not the
police nobody called an ambulance um and
the reason they didn't was because they
were absolutely terrified of doing
anything without his wishes
and even saving his life yeah even even
saving his life people are afraid and
some people have said that the reason
that nobody called a doctor or whatever
um was because
yeah sorry calling a doctor not calling
an ambulance they wouldn't have called
an ambulance there but yeah um nobody
bothered to call a doctor because they
wanted him to die i mean that could be
one reason as well but um but these were
some of his trust most trusted people
people like laurenti beria
and um
you know with stalin what happened was
that he was so ruthless and so
i mean he would he was known to sort of
kill people if they gave him bad news
and the same thing happened with saddam
hussein as well these people so bad they
kill people just for giving them bad
news and um
so people just didn't want to tell them
anything that they didn't want to hear
and this turned out to be very very bad
for for stalin because
um doctors were afraid to tell him if he
had a medical condition
you know um they didn't want to they
didn't want him to make make him they
didn't want to remind him that he's just
a human you know
and so what happened was overall he just
gradually became more and more distant
from reality and he became worse and
worse and worse
and
this is a pattern that you see
throughout history it's worse with the
authoritarians i don't know if this
really happens
with every leader because there are some
leaders who
are pretty open to hearing conflicting
views people like richard branson for
instance you know he was notoriously
kind-hearted and open-minded when it
came to hearing things from his
employees
um so it's not every leader but i think
authoritarians in particular and people
who are
people who any anyone who people are
afraid of yeah basically they're they're
dooming themselves
to
this life of illusion yeah you have this
uh you have this sort of predisposition
around tyranny or wanting wanting things
to be the way that you want them to and
then the world and your inner circle of
sycophants begin to reflect back to you
that which you want which means that you
become ever more attuned to anything
which is even slightly outside of the
thing that you want there's this uh tim
dillon went on rogan and there's not
many people that go on rogan and really
push back against him but tim has just
got so much
sass and wit and comedy i think that he
can get away with saying to joe and he's
obviously got an existing relationship
with him things that very few other
people could do
and
joe was talking about something like
uh i think tim was
lamenting
how
bad
the something seen is in la let's say
let's say it was a comedy scene in la or
something and joe said something like
well that's strange because you know
whenever i'm around the people in the
comedy scene and they've always been
really kind to me all that i've ever had
from them is you know warmth and
welcoming and stuff like that and tim
broke the fourth wall completely and
said
joe you do have to remember that you are
joe rogan
people are reflecting to you a world
which they wouldn't reflect to pretty
much anybody else because what they're
seeing in front of them isn't a person
it's a king
yeah absolutely yeah um yeah this is uh
this is one of the scary things i think
so it's not just authoritarians it's
also people that
are respected a lot you know so if if
somebody is really really respected then
other people won't want to
sort of seemingly damage their own
reputation in that person's eyes by
giving them bad news you know don't want
to they want to like you know bolster
their their sort of ego
and just say things that they they know
that the other person's going to be
happy to hear um
but i think this is actually this is a
much bigger problem than just
individuals i think that this is
becoming a systemic problem um if you
ever look online
the whole thing with censorship now
you've got
you've essentially got these massive
tech giants now who
can completely extinguish your online
existence if you say something that they
don't like
and what does this do is that this
creates a chilling effect where people
are now afraid to essentially tell
twitter or facebook
what it doesn't want to hear
which i mean and so we're now entering
this world where people are now posting
things that they know is going to be
acceptable on twitter and so they're
actually lying there they're they're
telling twitter and facebook what they
think it wants to hear
and
this i think is very dangerous because
people are now by proxy deceiving
themselves and they're deceiving other
people
it's something that i think
is one of the great arguments against
against censorship i think is that you
essentially you create this effect
um at scale so
it becomes a systemic issue it's not
just oh i don't want to displease stalin
or you know i don't want to displease
what i'm saying it actually becomes you
know i don't want to display i don't
want to
displease the internet
you know so
what can you do you know you literally
have to post online nowadays if you want
to have a life as a commentator as a
writer or even you know as a human being
you gotta you gotta post online
everybody posts online and so if you're
entering this environment where this is
the norm now where you have to be
careful of what you post
um what twitter is doing is it's
basically
it's putting a limit on honesty
you know that's that's what this kind of
uh censorship
is is happening with the censorship you
know it's
um it seems to be getting worse as well
i mean um
you know like uh
we saw it i mean even with the the
recent jerry sadowitz uh
uh comedy thing his his show was
cancelled because he i mean this is
jerry sadowitz we're talking about he's
one of the most controversial comedians
and he's been this way you know for like
uh
it's been about 20 years he's been doing
comedy probably longer than that but
he's notorious for being really
controversial and anybody who knows the
name jerry sadowitz knows that this guy
is probably one of the most defensive
comedians on the planet and yet he was
recently booked
at this place called the pleasants
and a few people complained i think
about two people complained about the
show
and so they they canceled the show they
cancelled the show and they said it's
racist and it's homophobic and it's
transphobic and all this stuff you know
the usual stuff and um
now like there's a lot of people like
really angry with the pleasants and
on the pleasant twitter page
you can see they've been ratioed you
know on their on their posts and there's
loads of just obscene stuff on there but
but basically what this comedy show has
done
is it's it's created this effect it's
basically now no comedian is going to
want to
um any comedian who works for this
company now is going to have to be very
careful about what they say so they're
just going to say
very bland very polite very
to sort of like you know
prosaic stuff
that that is not adventurous it's not
creative because they're
they're limiting themselves because they
know that if they don't
then they're going to get cancelled
and so this is a problem that extends
not just to individuals not just
powerful individuals but powerful
organizations everywhere and not just on
the internet also offline as well uh i
just don't understand why why why
organizations would do this you know
because
i mean the whole point of a person like
jerry sadowitz is to cross boundaries
that's why he exists you know that's his
whole shtick
is to cross boundaries and to make
people uncomfortable
um and so they've taken away the one
thing that he was actually there to do
and in doing that they've sanitized
comedy itself because now any comedian
who goes there is going to know what
they've done and he's going to be like
oh okay i'm just going to tell the
pleasants what they want to hear which
is going to be bland nonsense you know
just joking
yeah platitudes basically so
so this is a big problem everywhere now
deferred happiness syndrome the common
feeling that your life has not begun
that your present reality is a mere
prelude to some idyllic future this
idyll is a mirage that will fade as you
approach revealing that the prelude you
rushed through was in fact the one to
your death
yeah so i mean this is probably another
way of saying quite famous quote by
it wasn't john lennon who actually said
this but he's remembered for saying it
which is
life is what happens when you're making
other plans and um
i think this is a universal problem and
it's one certainly that i've
experienced in my life where you get
this kind of
feeling that you know oh you know my
life's not i'm not really living yet but
when i do this when i reach this goal
that's when my life will begin that's
when i'll really enjoy things that's
when i'll you know truly be you know
that's when i'll be alive and all sorts
of stuff but i've just got to get to
that position so people tend to sort of
section off parts of their lives
and then they in these sections they
kind of just
automate their lives they they tend to
just you know they just do what they
have to do and just they tend to focus
their attention on to the future and to
this sort of imaginary paradise where
they'll be in the in the future when
they're just when they've just achieved
x and y but then once they've achieved x
then they set new
goals for themselves you know and they
say oh okay yeah um i just need to
achieve why and then i'll be happy then
i'll be truly alive then i'll be able to
start my life and this just goes on and
on and on and it it seems to just carry
on into death you know then the point
comes
you're dead and then you can't really do
anything about it so
um
i think yeah this is something that is
really
a very seductive
uh
emotion to feel for people why do you
think it's seductive
because
we tend to
scapegoat
many of our problems on things that we
think you know like on that are not
actually affecting us now but which will
be that we can deal with in the future
so
um you know we tend to
escape our lack of happiness on
just some arbitrary thing and we'll
think that when we've resolved that
thing that will be happy you know
it's very easy to just find excuses for
why you're not happy basically so you
know you can just say oh the reason i'm
not happy in my life is because i work
at this job but what i'll do is you know
i'll work
for about two years i'll build up some
income and then i'll just find a better
job so it's easy to just you know shrug
all the problems off to the future and
say okay yeah that's the reason i'm i'm
uh i'm unhappy and i can resolve that in
the future you can always resolve things
in the future because as i said before
your future self is a superhero they can
do everything you know your future self
can solve all problems
you know it's
but when obviously when you get there
they can't they can't do anything
because they are you at the end of the
day
um
and so yeah this is this is the thing is
that we tend to scapegoat our problems
on just things that we think we can
resolve just like that easily
one event at a time
and this happens when we do resolve that
problem then we find that we've got
other problems and then we say oh okay
well i've just got to solve this problem
and then i'll be happy and it's
constantly if i just do this then i'll
be happy and that that thought process
there is the key that's the culprit
so i think
the solution
is to understand that your life is
actually happening now it's not
happening in your hopes it's not
happening in your memories it's
happening at the moment now and i know
that i said that now doesn't exist but
when i say now what i mean is that the
the the
space in which you can act basically the
space in which you can decide make
decisions and act
that is the place where your life is
happening and yeah that's slightly
divided between the present moment and
the past moment and the future it's it's
kind of like a
a little sort of triage of different
things at triad sorry of different
things but um
yeah that's the part of your life where
really if you want to avoid this this
problem um deferred happiness syndrome
you have to kind of understand that your
life is not going to be happening in the
future because if you
if you delegate problems to your future
self
you're creating a chain because your
future self tends to act a lot like you
jeremy and so he's gonna delegate to his
future self and then he's gonna delegate
to his future self so you have to make a
stand you can't push off the problems to
your future self because that person is
you at the end of the day and he's gonna
have the same
prejudices and the same laziness and the
same procrastination that you've got
um you're not gonna magically become a
superhero in the future this is the
illusion that a lot of people have they
seem to think you know oh just i'll do
it tomorrow i'm feeling a feeling i've
got a bit of a headache today i'll do it
tomorrow and i'm feeling better tomorrow
i'll feel great you know there's always
tomorrow that's the thing
you won't feel great tomorrow you're
gonna feel like you did today and so you
have to
wrestle with the present you have to
embrace the present and try to
understand that this is your life this
is actually happening now it's not
happening the future is not happening in
the past it's happening now and this is
the opportunity for you to actually make
a better life this is how you make a
better life yourself by acting now not
by thinking that you're going to do in
the future
so yeah dude i absolutely love that one
um talib surgeons you're considering two
people for a job one pretty one ugly in
achievements they're equal who do you
hire the pretty one
no the ugly one they accomplish just as
much while having a bias against them
always factor in other people's
prejudices
yeah so um
i mean this is quite a straightforward
one and i think what's interesting about
this one is
is the focus on on beauty causing
prejudice because i think that's
something that people don't really
consider much of we hear so much about
white privilege we hear so much about
male privilege but we don't hear about
the privileges which actually and
experimentally have a much greater
influence on life outcomes and those are
uh pretty privileged halo effect
yeah yeah the halo effect is is part of
it yeah and the pretty privilege
is what i call it because
it really is just
that pretty people just get way more
privileges in life than than ugly people
um this is a fact of life it's been
shown
um you know that they they are more
likely to be hired in job interviews
they are more likely to get higher
earnings they are more likely to have
the door held open for them you know
when they're when they're going into a
shop whatever there's just so many
little things and that that
attractive people and this is
particularly true of attractive women
because men tend to judge
people by their appearances
more than women do
and
so i mean attractive women are some of
the most
uh privileged people in in the world but
unattractive women are some of the most
unprivileged people
in in the world because there's this
huge you know there's a particular
pressure on women to be attractive and
um
and i think that this is something that
nobody talks about really you know like
i said we talk we hear so much about how
race or gender causes privilege um we
hear it all the time it's it's
all-encompassing on the left
particularly you know
but we never hear about uh
attractiveness and how much of a
privilege that is or even things like
height for instance height or for a man
like the depth of their voice you know
uh leaders uh more likely to be elected
if they have uh deep voices or if
they're taller
and and things like that you know we
don't really think about these things
and i think i've been wondering why that
is i've been wondering why there's a
double standard why there's a sort of
a pretty privileged privilege in a sense
in that the people who have pretty
privilege are privileged by the pretty
privilege in sense that people are not
going to complain about them in the way
that they do about people who've got
white privilege or male privilege you
know so
it's do you know i wonder about it i
think part of it is that i think part of
it part of the reason this happens is
that especially people on the left they
don't want to admit that there are such
a thing as as pretty people and ugly
people
because there's this whole thing about
how beauty is subjective fitness is
subjective you know big beautiful women
are just as beautiful as as slender
women
and
to a very small extent that's true
because if you have a look in older you
know medieval paintings and things that
the ideal woman was
sort of quite quite podgy full and yeah
yeah
and the reason for this i think was
because it was a sign of opulence
because if in an age of starvation if
you could eat a lot that was a sign you
were rich and you you know you were
affluent so i think it was it was a
socio-economic indicator but that's no
longer the case now in fact it's the
other way now being thin in an age of
abundance is a sign of affluence and a
sign of that you're taking care of
yourself conscientious orderly blah blah
yeah yeah because being overweight is
now the norm because we live in a world
of opulence and abundance and so the
beauty standards do they do they're
affected by cultural standards to a
certain extent but
but there is there is a core there is a
core
to what is there is a kind of universal
standard which is slightly swayed this
way in that but which remains generally
the same over time i wrote in my
newsletter about this that um the
optimal size body size for women has
indeed fluctuated over time but the
optimal waist to hip ratio has almost
always stayed the same it's about 0.82
so the same the same waist-to-hip ratio
so those are some of the fundamentals
that draw through and then you kind of
have fashions over the top it's like
saying oh well the girl that's in the
tight jeans and the high heels is hot or
if it was in the 60s it'd be the girl
with the dreadlocks and the baggy boot
cuts or whatever right like yeah it's
fashions that can kind of be laid over
the top of evolutionary precepts but
yeah i mean with with this the the
pretty privilege one of the reasons that
i could see for why this isn't used as a
um categorical identifier that gets
pointed at is that it's quite hard to
categorize
the good looks and beauty tend to be
a lot more crowd-sourced than race or
height say yeah yeah or sexuality that's
true it's a bit more subjective yeah in
that sense i mean i think it could it it
is possible to
to know if somebody's attractive i think
just generally like i mean you know if
you have a look at sort of um
for instance celebrities like most
hollywood actors and actresses are
attractive that's one of the reasons why
they're hired because they have that
universal appeal um
you know like uh
most people would agree that for
instance margot robbie is attractive or
um
matthew mcconaughey is attractive you
know and so it's like so there are these
kinds of um
uh universal standards and i think i
think yeah you're right i think it is
it's harder to gauge it but i think part
of that that difficulty comes not from
the actual difficulty of gauging
the um
the beauty but of admitting it as well
yes because you don't admit you don't
want to say oh this person is attractive
unattractive and that's why they're
being prejudiced against you
it's it's quite a hurtful thing to say
to somebody who's attracted to that the
reason that you're not getting work is
because you're unattractive yes uh
especially given it's strange because
unattractive is that maybe because it's
felt like that's more um there's a bit
more meritocracy in your attractiveness
than there is in your race that there's
something immutable about the race that
you've got or whatever um did you see
there was a
i think it was a youtube series it might
have been based on a british tv program
where they had
people
and they had to hold up signs was it of
who's got the highest iq and then people
had to put them into order and then
in the way that they predicted and then
people would move around or it was maybe
who earned the most or who something
else and something else and um people's
ability to choose
um things that are non-obvious
basically seems to completely go out of
the window and i suppose as well that
kind of what you were talking about
earlier on was it the nova nova effect
where you don't know what's going to
happen the effects of your effects and
downstream and so on and so forth yeah
you don't know what a miserable
childhood could compel somebody to do as
an adult yeah maybe having a perfect
childhood would be fantastic but because
the butterfly continues to go for a very
very very long time
you have no idea what the all the
permutations of the different
interactions that person had and the
chip on their shoulder and their desire
to prove their father wrong and blah
blah blah you know you just simply don't
know the outcomes so part of me is like
yeah absolutely i think that um
accounting for other people's biases if
you were to give me two versions of
someone and the
ugly person has managed to get to the
same level you're right that person's
overcome more they're probably more
skilled but you're trying to rationalize
you're trying to basically account in
for the halo effect or the pretty
privileged um
i think yeah this is a very interesting
point actually because then how does the
region beta paradox factor into this
because if somebody's unattractive
um they will also sort of bounce out at
the bottom so what you want the person
that's got the biggest difficulty is the
person that's average looking
they're the one
perfectly comfortable tell me about your
trauma well i haven't had that much
trauma but i haven't had no trauma right
you're amazing you must be really really
good uh okay interesting point yeah yeah
alder's razer there's two here that i've
grouped together because i think these
two work quite nicely alders razer if
something can't be settled by experiment
or observation it's probably not worthy
of debate this is because without
empirical evidence there is just your
word against mine and everyone wants the
last word following this rule will save
so much time and i think this goes along
with popper's falsifiability principle
for a theory to be considered scientific
it must be possible to disprove or
refute it as such for each of your
beliefs you should have a clear idea of
what would persuade you you're wrong
otherwise your belief is immune to
reason
yeah so
i think that most debates and
particularly online debates they're not
fact-finding exercises
uh their power struggles
so the you know the purpose of a debate
is not really to come to some mutual
understanding of truth
it's to dominate your opponent
and
this is something that has become
evident to me just from sort of my own
experiences i mean when i first joined
twitter in 2014
i was
i was just like going crazy i was
basically like anytime somebody
disagreed with me i would engage them in
argument and because i think you know i
could just change this because i can
make this person see my point of view
and i would do this all the time and you
know sometimes i would waste entire days
just
randomly
i learned from this believe me um but
yeah this was something that really you
know i was doing for like a while like
probably for the first sort of few
months of joining twitter i was arguing
with everyone and i wasted pretty much
just all my time because i never got
anywhere no matter how many arguments
how many good arguments i came out with
no matter how many um you know pieces of
evidence even so this even sort of you
know is a problem but um also i found
that i was doing the same thing i found
that when people were trying to convince
me of something i wouldn't listen and i
would just just dig deeper into what i
already believed and then this is when
it became clear to me that it was ego
was the issue wasn't lack of facts it
was ego
nobody wants to admit that they're wrong
and
people will do everything that they can
do
in order to avoid admitting that they're
wrong they will do literally everything
they can do to avoid being wrong
and so
it's it's pointless to debate somebody
when there is no hard evidence that can
completely disprove even then
even if you've got the evidence it's
often not worth debating because
you know you can
for instance like if you look at you
know i remember there was a a guy who
was
reading an argument between a flat
earther and a scientist
and the scientist was like just trying
to come out with all this stuff like
saying you know if you go to the
shoreline and you look at the the ocean
on the horizon you'll see that the sails
of ships appear before the prows
and so that's a sign that the world's
you know
a sphere and the guy was going no no no
no that's not true no no i i've looked
at this the beach plenty of times i live
near the beach and i've never seen that
happen you know so they just completely
deny the evidence and if you show them a
picture
taken from space of of the earth being
around they'll just say oh it's just
adopted photoshopped picture you know
that's not a real picture now so any
evidence like if if there's any way for
somebody to wriggle out
of this kind of voice that you try and
put them in when you debate them they
will they'll do it they'll use any means
possible and this is something that i've
learned from experience and i think
that's why it's just not worth debating
most things and really you've got to ask
yourself what really are you going to
achieve by winning an argument online
especially
not much the only times that i would
consider it worthwhile to debate is if
you're actually engaged in an official
debate
you know with a crowd with an actual
audience watching you because the
purpose of the debate in that case is
not to convince the opponent which
you're not going to do is to convince
the audience yes
um so that's a worthwhile time to debate
or
equivalently if you're online and you're
engaged in a debate with somebody who's
a blue tick and they've got 100 000
followers and they've got a big audience
and you know that they're going to be
over over what they're going to be
watching and eavesdropping on your your
your debate then then that's worthwhile
time to do it as well but in most times
it's just simply not worth debating
people because you're not going to
change their their mind
maybe once one in a million people
you'll be able to change their minds
because they'll be humble enough to
acknowledge when they're wrong but the
vast majority of people have got their
egos are way too big and they're just
not going to do it they're especially
not going to do it publicly if you want
to change somebody's mind you've got to
do it privately because if you do it
publicly they know that they're being
watched and that's going to obviously
make their ego even more they're going
to make that's going to make them
protect their ego even more that's the
the theory of bespoke [ __ ] all over
again right yeah yeah so i think uh
my stance on this is i i just i don't
engage with people that are illogically
critical online in a serious way they
either get no response or they get a
silly response
because the cost benefit that you have
if you if you start to invest yourself
psychologically emotionally
existentially and trying to change this
person's mind
you are just it's the equivalent of
pissing money away my dad would say
right you're just it's all downside from
here there is nothing it's worse than
yeah it's worse than pissing money it's
pissing away time which is even more
like money yeah you can't get it back
yeah yeah and so yeah i mean i've become
very jealous of my time uh recently you
know i've become protective of my time
i've basically because i realize that
it's the most important resource on the
planet there's nothing more important in
time because it's required for literally
everything else you cannot obtain any of
the resource without time
and so
you know and another thing like you said
is you could the only thing you can't
make more of once it's gone it's gone
and
debates are just
i mean this is going back to stoicism i
think it was uh uh seneca
who said that you know we are we
jealously guard our properties
uh physical properties but as soon as
someone starts taking away our time we
just let them have it you know as though
it's just free but it's not it's um
i mean that wasn't the exact thing that
he said he said that we we refrigerate
away
um like it's our
uh we know we switch away the the one
thing that we have the right to be
to guard of basically so um
so that was yeah that's essentially what
we do we sort of become very
um
prodigal with our time you know we're
very wasteful of our time
we tend to just throw it away even
though it's our most important resource
it's the thing that we need to acquire
all of the resources
and it's the only thing we can't make
more of and so this is why one reason
why i'm very careful about not debating
people because one just one reply on on
social media
can turn into
a slanging match which is gonna take the
rest of your day and it's not gonna just
take away your time it's gonna take all
your peace of mind because you're gonna
be constantly checking your phone for a
notification from this person and you'll
be like oh what is this bastard saying
now you know
i've come increasingly to believe that
sanity and peace of mind are probably
the
most important things to optimize for
when it comes to designing the way that
you live your life because you could
optimize your life in a way where risk
was ratcheted up a little bit more and
again this is
individuals some people's risk
tolerances may be different to mine or
whatever but
for me optimizing for peace of mind
insanity is
top of my list i want to be because
downstream from that is a whole host of
things that i really want to have but if
peace and sanity are
molested or perverted in a way
nothing else can flow from that easily i
remember
this is why i could never be a trader so
there was a period where me and all my
friends got hold of etoro and we're
going to start doing bets and our
activision's going to go up and let's
put money in netflix and spotify and
stuff and i would check it
10 times a day because i couldn't bear
not to check so my emotions got ragged
around at the mercy of the market
well
that's completely removed my peace and
sanity and how much would i pay to get
my peace and sanity back i would pay
way
way more
way more than whatever return i'm going
to get from this and all of the
externalities my lack of focus at work
my lack of ability to connect with my
friends the fact that now is the only
time that i want to reflect on a life
that's well lived all of these things
would be it was ruinous for everything
that i genuinely cared about to try and
optimize for something that was money
that i can make in a different way so
yeah that was uh
that was something that that it relates
to for me i think yeah i think
everything comes from from peace of mind
because um
you could you know you could have
everything you could have like
a mansion you could have
the most attractive woman by your side
you can have
any anything you could imagine you could
have right but if you don't have that
peace of mind
then all of it's wasted because you're
not actually able to enjoy it you're not
able to enjoy these things really all
comes from being able to actually have
enough serenity in your own head to be
able to enjoy things because if you
don't have that then everything that you
acquire everything else you require is
worthless you can't you can't get the
true value from it
again this is another idea from stoicism
you know this is the idea that you know
ultimately it's not about what's going
on in the external world it's about
what's going on in the eternal world
that's what matters to your your
well-being if you
if you if you if you don't have peace of
mind if you're constantly stressing
about things outside in the world
then you're not owning your own
well-being
the only way to own your own well-being
is to
looking inward and to actually try to
clean the room inside your head as it
were you know to get everything
organized and to not worry because when
you've got this kind of mess in your
head
that's where anxiety comes from that's
where you begin to become confused and
you think oh okay oh you know what's
happening here what's happening
your mind starts darting around because
it's got no order to it you know it's
it's just chaos and that chaos manifests
in your feelings so you could have all
the best things in in the world the
external world could be as ordered as
you want it to be but if the internal
world is not ordered then it's all
wasted it doesn't matter because you're
not going to be able to enjoy it so it
really all just began begin with with
the mind
gwyndol ladies and gentlemen everyone
needs to go and subscribe to your sub
stack which they can find at
gowinder.substack.com
and just to spell it out because a lot
of people have no idea how to spell it
sir
g-u-r-w-i-n-d-e-r dot sub stack dot com
go and check that out uh your twitter g
underscore s underscore bogle uh super
mega threads i'm sure that'll be coming
soon i highly recommend everyone goes
and reads the audience capture
uh article which you put out before and
we're gonna do a conversation on that
pretty soon so
dudes i i absolutely adore having these
conversations with you every single time
i rely on them i cherish them very very
much i'm sure that it adds tons of value
uh anything else any other bits that you
need to plug before we go
no that's fine just uh follow myself
stack on my twitter and everything
should be on there i think yeah all
right man appreciate you
nice one thanks what's happening people
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]